.
>>> AFTER FAILING IN HER
POLITICAL RUN, CLINTON IS TRYING
TO TEAM UP WITH HER DAUGHTER TO
EMPHASIZE MOVIES BY AND ABOUT
WOMEN.
THIS IS FOLLOWING IN THE
FOOTSTEPS WITH THE OBAMAS OF
CREATE TLG OWN PRODUCTION
COMPANY AND HAVE A DEAL WITH
NETFLIX.
GREG, THIS IS PROBABLY NOT ABOUT
WOMEN, RIGHT?
THIS IS PROBABLY JUST STILL ALL
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON.
>> IF YOU ARE NOT PRESIDENT,
HAVE A NETFLIX DOCUMENTARY ABOUT
PRESIDENT.
>> TRUMP WENT FROM ENTERTAINMENT
TO POLITICS.
SHE IS GOING FROM POLITICS TO
ENTERTAINMENT AND THIS LEADS ME
TO THE DISCUSSION.
SHE SHOULD HOST THE NEW
APPRENTICE.
WHAT IF THE RATINGS WERE BIGGER
THAN HIS RATINGS.
IT WOULD DRIVE HIM CRAZY.
ISN'T THAT THE PERFECT THING
THAT COULD HAPPEN?
>> YES.
>> NO.
NO ONE WANTS TO WATCH FOR
HILLARY.
AMERICANS HAD THEIR CHOICE.
SHE RAN FOR PRESIDENT TWICE.
SHE IS BORG.
SHE HAS BORING TASTE.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY CARE WHAT
IS SHE IS INTO.
IT IS A VANITY PROJECT FOR
HERSELF AND CHELSEA.
SHE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND HOW HARD
PRODUCING COMPELLING TELEVISION
IS.
IT IS ONE OF THE MOST
COMPETITIVE IN THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY.
HOW ARROGANT OF HER TO THINK SHE
CAN JUST SWOOP IN AND PRODUCE
THINGS PEOPLE WANT TO WATCH.
SHE IS GOING TO PUT HER NAME ON
A FEW THINGS AND GO TO THE
PREMIER AND WALK THE RED CARPET.
THEY HAVE THE NEWSPAPERS, THE
NETWORKS.
WHAT MORE DO THEY WANT?
GREG'S POINT?
DONALD TRUMP IS PROBABLY THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL TELEVISION
PRODUCER OUT THERE.
HE IS PRODUCING A HELL OF A
GREAT PRESIDENCY RIGHT NOW.
NO ONE IS GOING TO WATCH NETFLIX
WHEN YOU CAN WATCH TRUMP.
THERE IS NEVER A REPEAT.
HOLLYWOOD HAS GIVEN BE THE
CLINTONS SO MUCH MONEY.
THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH MONEY THEY
HAVE DONATED TO THE CLINTONS
SINCE 1990 WHEN HE WAS RUNNING
FOR GOVERNOR AND FOR PRESIDENT
AND FOR RE-ELECTION AND THEN
THEY ARE CAMPAIGNS AND THEN YOU
HAD THE CLINTON GLOBAL
INITIATIVE.
SHE IS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
ACTUALLY, WE WILL LET YOU DO
THIS TOO.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO
CONTINUE THE OBAMA VERSUS THE
CLINTON FEUD.
THE OBAMAS HAVE THAT BIG DEAL
WITH NETFLIX.
I HAVE THE REALLY STRONG URGE TO
GO BACK AND COMPLAIN ABOUT
SOMETHING.
>> SO THE QUESTION WAS, DO WE
HAVE THE WHEREWITHAL AND THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS.
I'M SORRY.
WE ARE ABOUT TO HONOR AND
OBSERVE THE 75th ANNIVERSARY OF
D-DAY.
GOING BACK TO 1944.
WE DON'T THINK WE HAVE THE
WHEREWITHAL AND THE ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY DEAL WITH A CRISIS IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES THAT IS
50 BLOCKS.
I AM PRETTY SURE THAT AMERICANS
CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THAT
DONE.
>> CAN I GO BACK TO A BLOCK FROM
FRIDAY?
>> I HAVEN'T HAD THAT URGE IN SO
LONG.
>> I KNOW WHY THAT IS.
YOU WANTED TO RESPOND TO ME.
I APPRECIATE IT.
I THINK IT IS A LEGITIMATE
CONCERN.
I AM LOOKING FOR IDEAS.
I THIS I THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO DO THAT.
>> LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
WHEN YOU GUYS LOOK AT WHY HUGE
BOOK DEALS COME IN FOR OBAMAS
AND THE CLINTONS.
OBAMA HAS A DEAL WITH NETFLIX.
I THINK CLINTON IS GOING TO GET
A DEAL.
WHY?
WE BELIEVE IN CAPITALISM AND
THESE CORPORATIONS SAY, HEY,
THERE IS A HUGE DEMAND FOR
POLITICAL CONTENT RIGHT NOW.
NOT ONLY ON THE CABLE CHANNELS.
YOU LOOK AT FACEBOOK.
YOU LOOK AT THE NEWSPAPERS THAT
ARE DOING SO WELL.
PEOPLE WANT POLITICAL CONTENT.
GUESS WHAT?
OBAMA AND CLINTON ARE GOING TO
PROVIDE IT.
>> THIS CONTENT IS BEING FORCED
DOWN THE VIEWERS NET.
OBAMA AND CLINTON SAY, WHAT DO
YOU THINK NETFLIX IS GOING TO
SAY?
THEY WANT TO BE IN BED WITH THE
GUY.
>> THEY ARE SHAREHOLDERS.
IF THE SHAREHOLDERS THOUGHT,
WE'RE GOING TO LOSE MONEY, THEN
THE EXECUTIVES WOULD.
THIS IS A MONEY-MAKING DEAL.
THIS IS A NICHE AUDIENCE FOR
CONSERVATIVES AND A NICHE
AUDIENCE FOR LIBERALS.
>> IT IS BY WOMEN, ABOUT WOMEN.
WHEN IS SHE GOING TO DEPART THE